everyone so we're very happy to Alex
tell us about regular right-down in
artillery hey thank you very much for
the invitation it's always a pleasure to
be back I should start by saying that
this is joint work with Damien Sierra
and forces back and that Mia is gonna be
on the job market next year so you know
what to do so just a little advertising
were recruiting non-tenure-track
junior faculty positions that nests in
data science whatever that is and it's -
your position with travel funds
competitive salary etc so if you're
interested in doing a good math in Pais
for about two years
please talk to me during the break okay
but today I want to talk about something
fairly generic we're going to focus on
the problem of minimizing a function and
what's important in this slide is what
is not there we're not going to make
that many assumptions about the function
but it's an unconstrained problem and
and that's that's important here
otherwise were not assuming that the
function is convex or anything like that
we will make certain a certain number of
assumptions to get rates but outside of
that the idea is simply to try to
accelerate a generic optimization algo
right so when you do optimization and
you learn an optimization algorithm on a
problem and here it's a very simple to
the example what you get is a sequence
of it is okay it's the quadratic
function minimization here using fixed F
brilliant descent and once you've run
the algorithm number of iterations
you throw away everything you've
computed except for the last point and
that's the standard practice in
optimization so from a statistical point
of view of course this is a disaster
right there's a lot of information we
have a sequence of points cover
converging towards the solution but
we're throwing away most of that
sequence except for the last point so
clearly we can do better than that and
in some cases like stochastic
optimization I going to actually keep
something else than the last point they
keep an average of the ETA rates or
something like that but typically in
optimization this is not what people do
you just keep the last point and work on
okay so we can do better by exploiting
the full sequence of e tides and the
idea is what kind of performance gain
can we expect and can we get bounce it's
a tower this is not a new idea of course
convergence acceleration on on on on
sequences and it dates back at least to
eight can in the in the 20s and I can
say search is very easy to spit out so
suppose you have a sequence of scalars
here with limit as tau and it follows
this autoregressive process here if you
have three points three tides you can
get a here
and if you plug in a inside the the
model you can get an estimate of estar
okay so this is the formula and that
that estimate is called eight cans Delta
square and it allows you to estimate the
limit estar using only 3 ETA lights
right we can do the derivation a little
bit differently and assume this linear
model between ETA AIDS with the
normalization constraint over here and
now instead of estimating the parameter
and plugging it into the model we simply
listed a certain number of linear
equations that have to be satisfied by s
and and the power model parameter a and
the limit s tau you get this linear
system you solve it and you recover I
can Delta square like we did in the
previous slide okay that's the same
formula as before but it's a different
approach and it's done using an approach
that can be generalized to higher
dimensions so again the idea you observe
three tides and using those three tides
you try to estimate the limit and this
seems to work amazingly well so just a
simple numerical example sequence here
that converges to PI over 4
ok the partial sums look like this and
after 10-digit 10 iterations so sorry
you get about one digit of position we
apply a TENS Delta square you use three
the three first e tights for example to
get an estimate of the solution and
after three iterations you get one digit
of precision
and if you do the same thing using the
last three taillights here you get this
estimate here to Delta square and now
you have four digits
you haven't computed anything else then
this initial sequence of iterates that
you're doing a little bit of
post-processing and this post processing
allows you to get three additional
digits of precision which essentially no
numerical cost the assumption you make
is that you're always in the context all
of the two meters that you mentioned
right
this one just no it's easier to think
about it in those terms so I have a new
target model but here it's not even
clear that the model is true right so
I'm just applying both phones I can see
Delta Square to this sequence and and
this is the kind of convergence I get
okay to make the result particularly
striking I've chosen purposefully an
oscillating sequence and this I can
that's a square turns out to be
particularly effective for selecting
sequences if the sequence was slowly
converging towards the solution I would
get less performance but here I'm not
doing that much more computation just a
little bit of post-processing and I have
four digits instead of one after ten
iterations and well it doesn't stop
there okay this is a perfectly
respectable sequence of iterates I can
accelerate it as well and one more time
and get an estimate of the limit and so
on that too is an old ID
it's called Vin's
Epsilon ago it made it back it did back
on the 50s and so there's an entire
stream of work on on convergence
acceleration dating back from numerical
analysis in in the 60s it's also of
course Jackie I related to the Levine's
and European procedure for example to
estimate auto Agassi processes most of
these results are focused on the scalar
case but there are also extensions to
the multi-dimensional case such as
minimal polynomial extrapolation which
I'm going to detail here because of
course in optimization
you're interested in the high
dimensional scenario okay
but overall the idea here is we're
looking at the post-processing step
we've run an optimization algorithm
idiots and we want to try to do a little
bit of post-processing on these iterates
to improve the quality of our estimate
of the solution at minimal medical cost
if the post-processing is more expensive
than the L going things start to fall
apart so here we don't invest too much
in Meg okay so I'm going to spend a
little bit of time by calling what
minimal polynomial extrapolation is
about and talk about the organization
version the regularize version and and
get convergence rates okay so to fix IDs
let's look at a quality example that you
minimize using the basic gradient method
so you're doing a fixed step gradient
fixed length the gradient steps and if
you write down what what's actually
happening you have this vector
autoregressive model linking iterates
between iterations okay and so we're
going to call the matrix of that model a
so XK plus 1 minus X now follows a
vector autoregressive process and if we
take linear combinations of those
iterates and the difference we text are
what we get is a polynomial in the
matrix a applied to the vector x0 minus
X star and if I normalize the the
weights to 1 then I can write that the
difference between a where C weighted
average of the iterates X I and the
limit is equal to some polynomial P of
the matrix a time's the vector x0 minus
X star and so in particular if somehow P
of a times x0 minus X star is equal to 0
then my C weighted average of the data
it is exactly the limit X star okay so
this is what we want to obtain in the
end so we get the limit by averaging it
rights using weights that of course
depend on those iterates in practice it
has to be a little bit more complicated
than that because well we do not observe
the matrix a and so the question is how
do we extract the weights C without
observing the matrix a well is the
answer we look at the increments if you
look at the model on increments this is
what iterations look like
and so if P of a is equal to zero we
must have that C weighted sum of
increments has to be zero to that plus
the normalizing constraint gives us a
linear system that allows us to solve
for the optimal weights C okay and so in
particular the polynomial P is the
minimal polynomial of the matrix a with
respect to X 0 minus X star so you solve
it in our system you get with C you
average it iterates using those weights
you get an estimate of the solution okay
of course K can be arbitrarily large
especially in high dimensions you don't
want to solve a very large in our system
because that's costly and so the idea is
to do this approximately and how do you
do this approximately well instead of
setting this quantity to zero you
minimize it okay and that means solving
a quadratic program again using this
normalization constraints on the
increment matrix u X I plus 1 minus X X
I and so you you're doing what we were
doing in the previous slide but just
approximately and this is also a
classical result it's known as the edema
sinner method or reduced hike
extrapolation with arbitrary K and it's
gonna get us an approximate solution to
the minimum polynomial extrapolation ago
it might detail before okay and the
question is how well does this does this
perform so of course we can't really
quantify how well this will perform but
there is a very good guess that works
uniformly well and involves chebyshev
polynomials and it's a classic argument
and the idea is this here is exactly
equal to this okay and again this can be
bounded by something that looks like a
condition number times some matrix
polynomial times x1 minus x0
okay again this quantity here is smaller
than this where this is the spectral
norm of the polynomial the matrix
polynomial P of a
again this is can be bounded by the max
of P of lambda I times the two norm of
this quantity and lambda I being an
eigenvalue of the matrix a okay
typically we don't know much about the
eigenvalues of the matrix a but we know
at least in many cases that they are
between 0 and Sigma typically when we
use gradient descent for example ok and
so minimizing this quantity uniformly
with without any specific knowledge on
it is simply solving a chebyshev problem
right so we minimize over all
polynomials P of degree K satisfying the
normalization constraint the maximum of
these polynomials over the segment Co
Sigma just the very definition of what
chebyshev polynomials do and we know
that this converge to 0 very very fast
this is actually the argument behind the
convergence rate for line shows
iterative methods to compute eigenvalues
accelerating power iterations for
example so we have very precise bounds
on how fast this converges to zero and
in particular we can show that it
converges to zero with a rate equal to
Zeta K where theta is this quantity here
and if you use if you look at exactly
what this quantity means when you're
using the gradient descent method on a
quadratic function with lower bound mu
and upper bound L on the spectrum the
rate you get is this one okay so the
difference between new estimate of the
solution and the actual solution
converges linearly to zero with a rate
equal to the accelerated rate okay so
you get square root of the condition
number here instead of the condition
number of other traditional in our
convergence so it's important to just
pause and understand what's going on
here okay we're running very naive fixed
step gradient iterations okay we get ETA
rates these are supposed to converge
very very slowly
we get those idiots compute the weights
ci we take a CI weighted average of
those iterates and now this average will
converge with the fast right okay so
we're on the very very naive gradient
descent method we do a little bit of
post-processing and we get the
accelerated rate of Nesterov this is in
the quadratic case and the question is
how can we generalize this to generic
optimization problems of course just a
few words about something I forgot to
say this too is very classical it's
known as chebyshev the chebyshev method
and it did back at least to enemy our
skin projector probably earlier than
that and that paper is in Russian and I
couldn't find it but I knew from
secondhand knowledge that everything
should be there a reliable source here
and so but but so it's a classical
technique and and they are interesting
connections with with classical
accelerated methods there's a Linkwood
conjugate gradient there's a similar
flavor but the key difference here is
that we do not observe a so it's not the
same story what's a little bit more
interesting is that in fact chebyshev
polynomials satisfy two step high
currents so this is what the recurrence
looks like and you can compare that with
the two step occurrence Johan when you
harnessed elf's method and they look
very similar okay and there are more
details in this paper by Mozart recently
okay so but you can look at Nestle's
method as doing a sort of closed form
version of the chebyshev argument I just
did it okay now so now the question is
can we do this for generic optimization
problems well this is just a noisy
version of what we were doing before on
quadratics at least locally if the
function is smooth enough okay so you
know a model likely like this holds in
the general case with some bounds on the
hessian and now the approximation error
in the end is a sum of three terms the
term the error term we had in the karate
case
a term which depends on the stability of
your estimation procedure on C okay and
a term which goes with the amount of
non-linearity you have outside of the
linear approximation in a okay and the
key issue here is is actually stability
why it's easy to see why if you look at
the matrix you're in in the linear
system you're solving to get the weights
it has a very specific structure by
construction it's going to look like a
killer matrix and that's bad news
because Calif matrix are inherently
poorly conditioned okay so the cred of a
problem is directly related to the
huncle or topics case and we know that
in those cases the condition number is
typically exponentially large okay so
that's bad news and so if you want to do
this on nonlinear problems you need to
regulate okay in particular for generic
optimization problems you have noise on
top of this what you observe is actually
a noisy version of that matrix and so we
are stability issues at stake but you
can legalize and it turns out that the
simplest possible form of organization
which is thick enough aggravation is
enough to remove this these two solid
stability issues so instead of solving
the original minimization problem you
solve this one with the penalty lambda
and of course the entire trick here is
to calibrate it's this penalty lambda
and you get optimal weights here and so
this is what the method actually looks
like it's very simple so why not spread
it out completely you won an
optimization algorithm whatever it is
you get a sequence of iterates you set
about a parameter lambda for
organization you form the matrix of
increments you solve the regulars in our
system you normalize the weight C and
you return the C weighted average of it
hides that's it okay and so we see how
this performs on general problems so you
can extend what was holding in the
trotty case to this none in our scenario
and you get a bound that is slightly
more obscure so
instead of having the classical bound
linearly converging bound for chebyshev
polynomials you get something is a
function of a highest version of the
chebyshev problem for which we do not
have a closed form solution but that
controls the error plus terms that
depend on the regularization parameter
the condition number and the amount of
non-linearity so that's a bit of cure
but it turns out that asymptotically
when you're close enough to the optimum
you can clarify a lot of things by
fixing the amount of regularization and
you can show that locally at least near
the optimum you'll recover the
accelerated convergence rate provided
you set properly the amount of
regularization and so you get again
linear convergence for dredging this act
basically extrapolated gradient descent
with the accelerated rate and again
what's going on here is you run the most
classical fixed step gradient descent
most naval going guys
you keep DTS and you take K tights of
this naive method compute the wid C
average those iterates with the wet C
and now you get an estimate of the
solution that satisfies the accelerated
rate in strf okay
bi is a scalar parameter that controls
regularization and is there P somewhere
Oh P is the amount of non-linearity so
in practice you do a great search on
lambda so this this is just a bound that
allows you to control the convergence on
paper in practice you try a few values
of lambda and you get an optimal list
you check the function value but I'll
show some numerical examples later on
okay so the idea is just to get rates
and to get rates you need the proper of
the magnitude fall under okay so that's
the terminus stick the question is can
you do this
thing for stochastic optimization and
the answer is yes and no otherwise
you'll be too simple so we get a similar
result for stochastic optimization that
depends on the amount of noise it's a
tower condition number again
so I wash over quickly over this but
there's an inherent conflict in doing
averaging for stochastic optimization
okay when you do acceleration in the
deterministic case and there's not too
much noise but what we've shown before
is that chebyshev polynomial provide a
sort of uniform answer that that works
quite well and actually gives you
optimal bounds but if you remember what
penuche polynomials look like the
weights oscillates it very significantly
so they are in condition and you're
taking averages of iterates with ways
there are weights that oscillate widely
okay when you're doing a stochastic
optimization and you have a lot of noise
it's so in the opposite scenario you
want to do the exact opposite and you
want to compute averages with uniform
weights okay so here there's a clear
conflict between what you're supposed to
do on the deterministic part of the
problem which is average with
oscillating weights and what you're
supposed to do on the stochastic part of
the problem which is average with
uniform weights right and I wish I could
say we had solved that conflict but we
haven't so in practice what you do here
is you set your way to accelerate the
deterministic phase of the algo when
you're actually working on the signal
and then sudden at some point it stops
working because the noise dominates and
and you're essentially producing noise
okay so that's fine because the
interesting phase in the convergence is
the first one but you would want to do
something a little bit more adaptive and
and work on the noise a little bit more
and we don't know how to do that yet
okay so we have these two extreme
scenarios when the noise is small you
recover the accelerated rate but with
weights that don't average very well and
when the noise is large you recover the
plain uniform averaging case and in that
case you are not accelerating very well
right so a few miracle results to
conclude so this is what happens when
you run this on logistic regression with
l2 regularization on the maintenant that
I said that star
something fairly standard right so in
gray here is fixed step gradient descent
orange is Nestor offs method the plain
vanilla one green is sorry purple is
Nestor off with backtracking this is
acceleration with using the last five
iterates okay and this is just the same
thing but with one last line search in
the direction given by your estimate of
the solution and this is what you get so
again it's it's interesting to think
about what's going on here we're using
the ETA rates produced by this method to
get these points right so when we're
here for example we use the last five
ETA rates of this algorithm we computed
the weight CI the CI weighted average of
the last five ETA rates we get to this
point we do line search in this
direction and we get to this point okay
it's just post-processing I'm running
gradient descent and doing
post-processing under gradient descent
it guides the line is used the last
point you got from your algorithm the
extrapolated one you do a simple line
backtracking line search in that
direction yes yes excellent question and
it doesn't work I mean it works but
basically what happens is that yes yes
yes but it doesn't decide it enough so
you're close you you have more
conditioning issues because all your
points are closer to the optimum so you
have to regularize more and if you
regula is a lot and you're close enough
to the optimum and you don't you lose
the benefit of acceleration so somewhat
paradoxically it it's better to optimize
a poor method than to optimize a good
one okay so and that's also because our
regularization is very good I'm sure
that if you do something wiser than then
thick enough you would get better
performance on the staff also the trick
is that nest elf is a multi-step method
and and so you're not exactly in the
setting that
described here because the matrix a is
not symmetric it's a town so I could go
on and on but that's the short story yes
it becomes to when you're close enough
to the optimum and the amount of
regularization is proportional to the
local nonlinear non-linearity
so that that's the ID yes yes yes and it
can be come out bitterly small but it's
just to get an ID it's one way of
formalizing the rights but you don't
really need decreasing of details to get
two of those ETH to get acceleration by
averaging so that's fine but the key
issue here as you said is basically nest
elf is a multi-step method and the
Meucci step means that we are not really
in this vector autoregressive framework
at least with asymmetric and as soon as
is not symmetric we don't get the
accelerated rates okay so it's better to
accelerate as small as a slow method but
it turns out that accelerating a slow
method still gives you fast rates so
it's enough in a sense other questions
good idea with sharpness and so on
may I we should try but this is
necessary with backtracking so it's the
locally adaptive one but we don't
restart yet and he start works when
there is sharpness so you have to then
specify the problem a little bit more
but it's another story okay so let me
just finish with the numerical results
so this is the same thing but for with
online stochastic gradient accelerated
stochastic gradient solving again
logistic regression there's a long
stream of work recent work doing
accelerated online stochastic gradient
by by using variance reduction
techniques and because the violence is
being reduced as they are going
progresses you can accelerate things a
little bit better than in a plain vanila
stochastic case I won't go into details
but basically accelerating the basic
stochastic gradient gives you a
performance like this and in some cases
accelerating for example saga which is
in gray somewhere gives you a an
improvement but again the picture is a
little bit more mixed and finally it's
sort of unavoidable these days we tried
it on your networks and and if you do
acceleration on the stochastic gradient
method plus momentum you get this head
curve here and this typically allows you
to a start a little bit sooner and if
you start sooner you go faster but there
there's a very very long Lee so this is
one scenario which works but choosing
the right parameters the right
configuration for the algo in the height
they start frequency it's da is still
more an art than anything else and so we
haven't found a robust strategies to
speed up the convergence yet okay so it
works sometimes I can show you an
example that works but I can guarantee
that we have a robust restart strategy
and it's there for accelerating neural
networks yet okay but here for example
once you have the proper tuning you get
a speed-up of a factor about two okay so
just to conclude post processing works
so if you remember one thing from this
talk is that when you run an
optimization
that it probably makes sense to recover
the last few kites and try to go a
little bit further by doing averaging
like here like like we did here okay it
in practice it means solving a linear
system typically five by five or ten by
ten so the numerical investment is
absolutely minimal and if you're lucky
and and in many cases at least in the
convex case where things are smooth
enough this will work you're going to
get a much improved estimate of the
solution okay so the complexity is
completely marginal so it makes sense to
try it no matter what and and again in
practice we do get a convergence
speed-up over optimal methods even the
adaptive ones okay and it's adaptive it
doesn't need any knowledge of the
smoothness parameters and no not using
any information about the strong
convexity or the Lipschitz constant of
my gradient okay that's a feature it's
also a bug I should maybe I should be
using this information if I have it or
if I have estimates of the strong
convexity constant nu and an L but
because the regularization I'm doing
here is very naive
I'm not accounting for this additional
structure of the problem and that should
probably who think a little bit but we
need some different kind of
regularization and so there's still a
lot of stuff to to do maybe we might be
able to extrapolate accelerated methods
if we can solve the stability issues we
need to work on constraint problems so
adding a convex constraint shouldn't be
that hard
it probably means convex but it's going
to increase its complexity significantly
because now you have an extra
feasibility constraint on the linear
system you solve to get the
extrapolation weights and it's not clear
at all that extrapolation remains very
very cheap okay so that's going to
depend on problem structure but it might
work otherwise and we should handle
smooth functions a little bit better so
just to finish with a short list of open
problems so again we should haggle eyes
in a more structured way okay we are
estimating the limit of a vector
autoregressive sequence with a fixed
point which would account for that in
the way we
we don't do it yet we have information
the spectrum of the modal matrix a we
don't use it and compute when computing
C we should it should help and also
there is this change regularize
chebyshev problem we can solving using
several squares okay but we don't have
explicit bounds on it convergence as a
function of alpha and if we want to
improve the results on stochastic
optimization we need to better
understand the impact of regularization
on the convergence of these bounds but
I'm not sure yet how to get bounds on on
a problem like this outside of just
solving it using SDP
ok so that's it for today thank you
[Applause]
good idea I haven't tried but so because
it's simple gradient descent in a sense
it's fixed up gradient descent so the
gradients are implicitly inside detail
it's actually now transformed but if you
use wiser methods suddenly this link is
not clear anymore so I guess you might
be able to do something and it may have
to do with a more structured way of
regularizing the weights estimated
estimation problem
okay let's thank thank you
[Applause]